des ballots de matière recyclables
s'accumulent par dizaines au centre de
tri de la Chine l'entreprise recova qui
exploite le site n'arrive pas à vendre
ses ballots à l'international elle a
visé la ville qu'elle pourrait cesser
ses opérations pour nous
on peut pas avoir un bris de service en
matière de collecte du recyclage
Montréal compte résilier le contrat de
recova c'était la piètre qualité des
ballons fait parikova qui créa le
problème initial donc quand on a décidé
de résilier le contrat et qu'on a
cherché des nouveaux opérateurs on a
cherché aussi une certaine assurance
quant à la qualité le centre de tri
appartient à la ville
ericova soutient que l'équipement est
inadéquat pour répondre au volume de
matériaux recueillis à Montréal mais
l'entreprise est dans l'embarras depuis
des mois en février l'émission enquête
révélait que les ballots avaient des
taux élevés de contamination avec des
matières plastiques notamment en mars le
bureau de l'inspecteur général
recommandé à Montréal de résilier le
contrat de recova
réagir et faire sonner la lame aux
effort et maintenant on est six mois
plus tard et rien que tu es fait en date
Montréal assure que les opérations de
recyclage se poursuivront sans
interruption l'eau PNL via exploite déjà
400 de tri au Québec elle devrait
reprendre le flambeau mais ce ne sera
pas du jour au
lendemains comme tel donc ça peut
prendre de quelques semaines à quelques
mois l'entreprise recova devrait
conserver certaines ces contrats avec la
Ville de Montréal notamment ceux liés à
la collecte de matières recyclables
recova opère aussi un autre centre de
tri situé dans le quartier Villeré
Saint-Michel Parc Extension et ici aussi
les ballots de matière destinées au
recyclage s'accumulent ici
Marie-Isabelle Rochon Radio-Canada
Montréal